je vous propose que nous démarrions un
moment
comme tous les moments qu'il y a eu
d'ailleurs depuis le début mais
sympathique
nous allons
nous entretenir et je vous remercie de
vous asseoir
alors je suis
particulièrement heureuse
d'être aujourd'hui
avec David Smetanine
qui est un grand champion
un très grand champion
je vais vous le présenter quand même si
vous avez forcément entendu parler de
lui parce que il est quand même ça fait
20 ans qu'il est en équipe de France
même peut-être plus
20 ans
grand champion paralympique
il nage il fait de la natation pratique
la natation il a participé à 5 jeux
paralympiques
9 médailles dont 2 à Nord 5 an argent et
deux embronze
c'est pas fini
il a participé à 7 championnats du monde
10 médailles dont trois nord de
anarchent 5 en bronze
si championnats d'Europe 11 médailles
dont trois à Nord 3 argent et 5 en
bronze et 156 titres de champion de
France un record sur le plan national
alors là vous pouvez l'appeler après
alors c'est pas tout parce que il habite
Grenoble très investi dans la promotion
l'évolution du parasport dans
son département de l'Isère il est
ambassadeur
auprès du sport du département de
l'Isère il a été conseillé régional
de cette grande région
et
[Musique]
il a également une travail dans une
société de conseil voilà donc et il m'a
dit parce que nous avons déjeuné
ensemble qu'il avait bien l'intention
d'être présent au jeu paralympiques de
2024 alors je lui ai dit mais dans
l'organisation non non dans la piscine
alors moi j'ai une question d'avis de
très simple comment faites-vous
et quelles sont surtout
quelle est de façon concrète
la préparation nécessaire pour
participer à une compétition telle que
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
pour vous voilà concrètement qu'est-ce
que ça représente
merci pour cette présentation qui est
assez complète en effet
mon engagement en tant que membre
différentes commissions sportives et
puis maintenant
auprès de ma société en essayant
d'apporter des conseils aux entreprises
et aux collectivités en matière de sport
d'éducation et
de handicap à ce sens large on parlera
d'accessibilité d'ailleurs avec madame
la ministre c'est important
c'est aussi une facette importante pour
moi de pouvoir rendre sport ce qui m'a
apporté et puis de pouvoir
contribuer au réellement notre société
mais pour si la partie sportive c'est un
entraînement quotidien tous les jours
comme tout à fait de haut niveau
d'ailleurs dans notre discours je pense
que vous l'entendrez on fera très peu la
différence entre le sportif de haut
niveau olympique et paralympique on
parle d'un nouvel anachronie mais job à
Paris les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
c'est important de de la culture les
gens à cette chose là et de pouvoir dans
notre pays faire en sorte que ce
mouvement paralympique prenne toute sa
place peut-être la même place que prend
aujourd'hui le mouvement national
olympique sportif français
voilà donc Brigitte Henri IV c'est
maintenant à la tête
une personne fantastique
c'est l'entraînement tous les jours
c'est un vrai travail à temps plein même
si je fais d'autres choses on se lave un
peu plus tôt que les autres
d'où l'expression le monde appartient à
ceux qui se lève tôt surtout ce matin
pour venir jusqu'à ici jusqu'à Guidel
mais j'en suis ravi mais oui oui ça
commence le matin très tôt pour
s'entraîner et pour pouvoir travailler
ensuite et puis retourner à
l'entraînement quand c'est nécessaire
et c'est une passion qui m'allume depuis
maintenant plus de 20 ans 20 ans en
équipe de France en effet où chaque
construction d'un projet paralympique a
été une véritable histoire avec des
championnats d'Europe de championnats du
monde à chaque fois comme une
phase une étape intermédiaire
un peu comme une vie de tout homme
professionnel qui a différents objectifs
et qui pour arriver à un projet final
on valide certains qui sont des projets
intermédiaires
voilà j'ai écouté moi aussi les débats
tout à l'heure et les discours et
beaucoup similitudes avec la politique
avec l'engagement en général que l'on
prend dans le sport
c'est un engagement sans faille
transparent honnête
et qui prend en compte pas mal de choses
notamment l'environnement et puis
surtout la partie humaine la relation
entraîneur entraîne est très importante
et c'est ce qui fait que tout cet
écosystème fonctionne bien et permet de
pouvoir réussir un projet une fois deux
fois trois fois jusqu'à 5 fois et
peut-être même six fois c'est tout se
passe bien après ça dépend que de nous
que de moi et de mon entraîneur aussi
mais du travail qu'on va fournir au
quotidien et pour ça il faut être
passionné il faut être motivé et je
crois que c'est ce qui m'a le plus animé
depuis toutes ces années c'est la même
passion et d'écrire une nouvelle page à
chaque fois que je m'engage à refermer à
préparer c'est le bon lieu pour ça la
bonne opportunité
[Musique]
et quand on a la chance de pouvoir vivre
cette cette ce moment là c'était bon là
en France chez soi il faut en profiter
voilà c'est formidable et
donc on a introduit un petit peu le
sujet des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques et d'ailleurs puisque Joe
on peut dire jeux de Paris
puisque voilà ça représente vrai
vraiment le l'ensemble de ces Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et ces jeux
vont être l'occasion de de donner
un
fort éclairage justement sur le
paralympisme
sur le handicap aussi au sens large et
bonne vont nous permettre j'espère
puisque c'est dans l'ambition de ces
jeux de pouvoir
bien tracer un peu un chemin différent
plus volontariste et surtout plus
complet dans ce qu'on appelle
l'accessibilité universelle alors c'est
un terme qui est employé de plus en plus
de plus en plus fréquemment mais moi
j'ai
je veux demander à David qu'il vous
explique qu'il nous explique de façon
très simple et très concrète qu'est-ce
que l'accessibilité universelle
qu'apporte le mot universel au surplus
en plus à l'accessibilité que l'on
connaît bien c'est un terme que l'on
connaît bien et
on va voir un véritable moment où nous
pourrons accélérer de jeter vraiment
toutes nos forces pour faire en sorte
que cette accessibilité universelle soit
en fait le fil rouge de toutes nos
politiques dans les années à venir mais
David l'accessibilité universelle c'est
quoi
alors oui il y a un rayonnement énorme
avec Paris 2024 notamment grâce aux Jeux
paralympiques d'été je rappelle c'est la
première fois qu'on peut accueillir ces
jeux là en France on a eu la chance
d'avoir Albertville 92 qui a consternant
changé le territoire et qui a permis
aussi de rendre ces deux vallées de la
désenclaver là parenthèse et la moyenne
et de les rendre accessibles à tous
pour autant ça dépassement de
l'accessibilité universelle ce qui
concerne Paris c'est différent puisque
au-delà des bâtiments sportifs des
équipements sportifs ou de la du village
bien entendu ou de la de l'accès aux
aéroports on veut que la ville elle-même
est tout ce qui la compose les commerces
la voirie les transports en commun etc
soit rendu accessible et quand on
universel c'est parce que ça concerne
tout le monde dans le sens où
un projet olympique et paralympique des
reines des touristes des professionnels
des athlètes en cession de handicap ou
non et c'est accessibilité se veut donc
pour tous permettre d'avoir un
accélérateur d'inclusion pour tout le
monde
on va dire une faire une pierre deux ou
trois ou quatre coups peut-être
Paris n'est pas une ville forcément très
accessible notamment en matière de
transport en commun elle a fait de gros
progrès mais pour ce qui est du métro
par exemple qui est une solution très
rapide de transport ce n'est pas encore
le cas et de rendre un équipement
accessible ou un lieu accessible par
rapport à une personne qui est en
cession de make-up
c'est aussi ouvrir une porte pour des
personnes qui ont un besoin ponctuel
parfois et qui renvoie ce terme
d'accessibilité universel la règle de
droit elle est simple on l'applique on
l'applique pas quand on applique pas les
pénalités quand on applique pas on a des
fois des dérogations malheureusement on
écoute tu mets du fait chez nous
j'espère que ça va changer
mais par contre il y a ce qu'on appelle
la qualité d'usage qui concerne tout le
monde et qui fait que ce mode
d'accessibilité universel prend tout son
sens voilà
alors
c'est un bon résumé c'est pouvoir aller
partout sans se poser la question de
savoir si on peut y aller il faudra
prendre un chemin dans l'idéal j'entends
oui et quel que soit les formes de
handicap et de quel que soit les formes
de handicap que ce soit un handicap
moteur que soit un handicap sensoriel
qu'on soit aveugle qu'on soit sourd
qu'on puisse avoir les informations et
que l'on puisse se déplacer
son contrainte dans dans une dans une
ville ou dans un espace
et que l'on puisse effectivement
assurer la mobilité sans contrainte non
plus
et il y a un pan essentiel dans
l'accessibilité universelle c'est le
numérique
qui est un vrai un vrai enjeu et qui va
là aussi alors j'ai tout à fait
confiance dans le fait que pour les Jeux
Olympiques tout ce qui sera numérique
sera accessible totalement mais nous
avons un enjeu à l'échelle de notre pays
c'est de rendre par exemple la
communication de notre gouvernement
accessible
accessible alors
nous avons fait 50% du chemin mais nous
en avons encore bien un petit peu à
réaliser
mettre en ligne de façon accessible par
exemple
des
des dossiers les dossiers les plus les
plus demandés par la population et ça
c'est un véritable enjeu et c'est un
enjeu qui
que nous devons où nous devons continuer
et continuer d'accélérer pour que chacun
puisse avoir l'information les capacités
à faire à réaliser des dossiers comme
les autres et puis savoir aussi
l'information citoyenne savez-vous que
dans la dernière la dernière campagne
présidentielle et législative les
candidats étaient
devaient
également avoir une communication
accessible et donc nous avons eu nous
avons dû nos documents électoraux les
rendre accessibles sur sur internet donc
je pense pour que les personnes
situation de handicap et la même
possibilité d'information citoyenne que
toutes les autres personnes de tous les
autres citoyens et je crois que ça c'est
un voilà un progrès et un progrès tout
simplement
pour faire rentrer chacun de façon égale
dans la citoyenneté dans la ville avec
l'accessibilité des voies dans les
transports mais aussi dans l'information
et dans l'information citoyenne donc
nous avons vraiment
un grand grand travail à faire et je
voudrais rappeler à tous ceux qui sont
élus quand même qu'il y a des
contraintes d'accessibilité avec des
adaptes dans toutes les communes qui
doivent être fini de réaliser en 2024 il
faut il va falloir véritablement que
nous mobilisions chacun pour savoir où
nous en sommes de ces programmes
d'adaptation des établissements recevant
du public et également des
établissements communaux recevant du
public dont nous avons
un véritable enjeu de poursuivre la mise
en accessibilité dans notre pays pour
lequel les choses devraient être
réalisées depuis déjà bien longtemps
donc 2024 c'est une date qui est très
très rapide c'est la date des Jeux
Olympiques c'est dans deux ans et pour
revenir à nos jeux
il y a un engagement très fort
pardon il y a un engagement très fort
des médias pour retransmettre
intégralement les Jeux paralympiques
donc les Jeux paralympiques vont avoir
la même la même couverture médiatique
que les Jeux Olympiques et ça c'est
quelque chose de formidable pour pouvoir
justement on l'a vu dans les jeux de
Tokyo par exemple qui ont été retransmis
intégralement et ça a eu un véritable
impact sur la population alors là les
heures de les heures étaient pas tout à
fait faciles à suivre par contre à Paris
ça va être très facile à suivre pour
pour nous Français et au moins dans
l'Hexagone
parce que certains sont avaient des
décalages horaire mais dans l'Hexagone
ce sera très facile à suivre et je pense
que là aussi nous allons pouvoir
sensibiliser sur le handicap les
différents types de handicap les
différentes origines des handicaps et
puis surtout changer le regard et faire
en sorte faire en sorte que nous
considérions les handicaps n'ont pas
comme quelque chose d'incapacité mais
comme quelque chose au contraire
sont des personnes avec des capacités
avec des compétences physiques
intellectuelles et que toutes ces
compétences et ses capacités et bien
elles sont
fortement mises en oeuvre dans ces
épreuves je vous laisse la parole
il faut rappeler qu'il y a aucune forme
de discrimination et même simplement
l'état civil n'a pas toujours document
qui sont accessibles pour ce qui est du
sport effectivement c'est un levier
vraiment intéressant pour pouvoir
avancer et on veut que c'est juste par
exemplaire on parle de 300 ans de direct
marché qui a été proposé un appel
d'offres TF1 quand il a été France
Télévisions qui a déjà fait un très gros
travail
quand il était elle aussi et puis ils
ont remporté ce marché dans 300 ans
direct ne sont promis c'est vraiment
important et on espère que ce impact
qu'il y aura
la résonance est pas qu'en France mais
je pense à l'Outre-mer nos amis
Tahitiens puisque le surf sera à tupo
Polynésie française
auront la chance aussi de pouvoir avoir
ce rayonnement là et une prise en
conscience importante une prise de
conscience qui est nécessaire je pense
mais oui ce que l'on diffuse à la
télévision Grand Prix de grand public
permet de pouvoir sensibiliser les
personnes de prendre conscience d'ouvrir
des portes aussi pour la jeunesse et
puis de leur donner de l'espoir d'être
eux aussi des sportifs des grands
champions d'inspirer notre jeunesse
qu'elle soit olympique ou paralympique
sans faire de discrimination
au sein de nos équipes de France
olympique et paralympique on a
maintenant un même logo c'est une même
équipe qui collabore de plus en plus qui
change de plus en plus qui partagent de
plus en plus je suis qu'au présent d'une
commission du comité des sportifs de la
FLD l'agence française dont il de page
et ma coprésidente est une athlète
valide à yodelé cuisson en athlétisme
notre composition de la commission est
très claire elle est moitié handisport
moitié valide
donc c'est toute cette mixité qui donne
un rayonnement fort et puis une certaine
légitimité à ce que l'on veut mettre en
place dans notre pays c'est important et
le sport il contribue grandement donc
l'opportunité nous est vraiment donné
grâce à Paris il ne faut pas rater le
virage cette fois-ci
et alors ne pas rater le virage après
qu'on ait envie de donner d'abord après
qu'on est pour la sensibiliser tous les
Français à l'accessibilité au sport aux
capacités des personnes en situation de
handicap il faut aussi
garder un héritage de ces jeux et dans
ces jeux il y a toute une partie
héritage qui est absolument essentielle
c'est-à-dire qu'allons-nous garder de
ces Jeux Olympiques nous en garderons
bien sûr l'accessibilité tous les lieux
qui ont été rendus accessibles et ben ce
sera un héritage très positif mais le
deuxième héritage c'est que nous devons
impulser l'accès au sport des personnes
en situation de handicap et ça c'est un
enjeu majeur et il est dans la dans
cette stratégie d'héritage notamment
prévu de
pousser fort pour le développement des
des clubs accueillants du
parrasport 3000 clubs afin que il y a
aujourd'hui mis le club qui accueillent
du parasport l'objectif c'est d'aller à
4000 et de faire en sorte que une
personne en situation de handicap puisse
dans un rayon de 30 minutes de
déplacement ou allez moi je suis dans un
département où c'est très vaste on va
dire trois quarts d'heure on puisse
avoir une structure qui accueille pour
pouvoir faire du sport et je crois que
cette
héritage est particulièrement précieux
mais je sais que vous m'avez demandé
vous m'avez dit est-ce qu'il y a des
élus dans la salle
parce que je voudrais leur passer des
messages
je vous laisse la parole
oui un engagement fort on sait que
l'État est souverain en la matière et
que c'est lui qui coordonne la politique
sportive mais la délègue aussi aux
communes et il faut que la commune
puisse s'en saisir alors ce label terre
de jeux dont on parle beaucoup qui
permet aux communes de pouvoir justement
proposer des projets et d'insuffler
cette dynamique cette politique sur le
plan local elle demande des moyens on en
est conscient mais elle demande aussi un
engagement de la part des élus et
l'engagement de la part des
collectivités pour pouvoir faire une
activité le sport c'est vraiment la
social extraordinaire c'est le premier
lien social au monde et cette capacité
qu'on a grâce au sport et ses événements
comme les jeux que sont les jeux de
pouvoir séduire les jeunes de pouvoir
les engager aussi comme des acteurs
citoyens responsables et de leur donner
une certaine visibilité aussi par leur
action c'est important donc
bien sûr que je regarde les communes en
premier à saisir du dossier et de
pouvoir avancer alors je suis conscient
bien sûr madame messieurs les élus que
la problème la problématique aujourd'hui
celle des équipements sportifs qui nous
manquent de la mutation des équipements
voilà qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comment
conjuguer avec ça est-ce qu'on peut
améliorer les choses est-ce qu'on peut
saisir peut-être d'un partenaire privé à
un moment donné
de façon à ce que cette mutation soit
bénéfique pour tous et surtout qu'elle
rende service à tous nos jeunes
générations qui elle aussi ont besoin de
s'émanciper notamment parce que le sport
c'est aussi la santé comme vous l'avez
dit à juste titre et que cette santé là
elle est primordiale faire du sport
c'est d'abord s'insérer dans un contexte
sanitaire important et j'aime souvent
dire sont pas mémos mais je les ai
entendus ils m'ont beaucoup marqué que
les médecins solutionnent des problèmes
de gens qui sont déjà malades la
prévention est encore plus importante le
sport et préventif dans ce sens là
il faut en profiter pour justement
multiplier les opérations sportives et
l'action en faveur du sport dans les
communes pour que nos enfants et toutes
les générations d'ailleurs qui sont
intéressées par le sport puis justement
bénéficier elle aussi être en meilleure
santé on réduira aussi
clairement je pense
la dette de la crise sociale grâce au
sport parce que prescrire du sport parce
que faire du sport c'est
s'éloigner de la question médicamenteuse
de plus en plus et puis c'est resté en
bonne santé tout simplement le plancton
possible on prescrit maintenant le sport
l'encourage en entreprise on s'en
imprègne un peu partout mais les
premiers concernés ce sont les
collectivités parce que le sport aussi à
l'école doit trouver une véritable place
une place qui n'a pas encore aujourd'hui
pas une place de grande qualité voilà
bravo
c'est vrai que cette cette accès au
sport il a il a plusieurs facettes vous
l'avez dit le ministre de la Santé de la
prévention ce matin par les du sport
santé
et le sport santé c'est de la prévention
en fait et on entre aussi dans la
prévention quand le président de la
République a dit 30 minutes de sport à
l'école tous les jours et il est
absolument indispensable et nous y
travaillons pour qu'il y ait également
30 minutes de sport dans tous les
établissements médico-sociaux tous les
jours parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison
c'est les mêmes enfants c'est les mêmes
c'est les mêmes jeunes et ils ont tout
le monde a besoin d'avoir cet exercice
physique et des références sports
doivent être nommés seront nommés dans
tous les établissements médico-sociaux
afin de pouvoir justement mettre en
œuvre cette cette ce sport prévention
qui est cet exercice physique c'est
l'exercice physique prévention qui est
essentielle et ensuite il y a le sport
lui-même on peut vouloir faire un
exercice plus régulier
du sport d'équipe du voilà il y a des
choses qui ne peuvent se faire qu'en
club et c'est là où bien sûr pour
inciter les clubs à pouvoir
évoluer faire cette pratique du
parasport nous allons dans l'héritage
bien sûr aider à se développement avec
il y aura bien entendu des soutiens
financiers et des soutiens financiers
surtout aussi pour souvent vous savez
c'est pas tellement l'accès ou ça elle
est en général pas trop mauvaise quand
même
il n'est il est l'accès pardon qui est
masculin l'accès n'est pas trop mauvais
mais
ce qui manque c'est du matériel
spécifique donc il faut pouvoir voilà
aider les communes aider les clubs
surtout à acquérir ce matériel et à
faire en sorte de pouvoir développer le
parasport vous savez moi j'ai je suis
très frappé parce que dans cette
histoire de sport
quand j'étais mère il y a quelques
années j'avais
assisté à une assemblée générale comme
on le fait quand on émerve en assiste à
toutes les assemblées générales dans nos
communes bien souvent et j'ai une
commune très sportive et j'étais dans
l'assemblée générale de mon club de
rugby et amateur
omnisport et je bon je les écoutais
c'est un peu long en plus bon il y avait
que des hommes qui parlaient tout ça bon
et à la fin je leur ai dit écoutez moi
je vous donne un je vous donne un
challenge à relever c'est de faire une
équipe de rugby féminine
ils m'ont tous regardé
et ils se sont mis en oeuvre ils ont
retroussé les manches et ils ont mis en
oeuvre une équipe de football féminine
parce que le sport ou féminin c'est
aussi c'était un grand oubliés dans les
dans certains sports j'ai fait la même
chose avec le foot ils l'ont fait et
bien maintenant l'enjeu que nous avons
c'est de dire à nos clubs de sport aussi
le sport masculin le sport féminin le
parasport voilà on développe parce que
c'est taxé au sport il est absolument
essentiel parce que je crois que ça
construit les personnes ça construit les
physiques mais ça construit aussi le
cerveau ça construit le mental ça
construit la solidarité ça construit
voilà l'envie l'envie de partager d'être
ensemble et s'il y a bien quelque chose
qui est important dans l'inclusion dont
on parle le temps des personnes en
situation de handicap c'est justement
d'être complètement inclus dans une vie
de société sans
son frein sans frein majeur et de se
sentir à l'aise dans tous les dans tous
les milieux de façon de façon naturelle
donc je crois que le sport est un
excellent vecteur est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord oui je pense oui oui bien sûr
mais vous avez sûrement vous avez
peut-être me dire qu'il y a des freins
qu'il y a des choses à lever qu'il y a
voilà c'est ça que je voudrais entendre
parce que c'est vous qui pouvez de nous
apporter ça il y a encore un combat
lever bien sûr sur la formation
notamment on dispute formation qui est
très fort sur le mouvement olympique et
qui est encore un peu plus faible au
niveau paralympique il faut trouver les
structures qui accompagnent ces
personnes là parce que vous voulez être
justement le sport aussi une question de
santé primordiale une personne qui est
handicap le fait que sportive elle s'est
vite plein de problèmes c'est une sorte
de prévention si vous voulez qui est
important qui est nécessaire donc le
sport pour une personne qui est handicap
ça n'est pas un luxe c'est pas une
activité uniquement loisir c'est aussi
une prévention quotidienne de tous les
jours comme le sort devrait être intégré
30 minutes sur le président par jour
comme quelque chose de normal on se
levait matin on fait un peu de sport on
est en meilleure santé on est réveillé
physiquement aussi nous on appelle ça
l'échauffement chez nous et ensuite on
plonge vraiment dans le bain sans faire
de mauvais jeu de mots pour pouvoir se
mettre à l'entraînement ou au travail
tout simplement mais il y a forcément un
regard particulièrement les jeux doivent
renforcer cette pratique sportive mais
aussi tout le volet autour de formation
d'accompagnement les équipements en
effet on fait un gros travail la mise en
possibilité universelle sera
intéressante pour pouvoir desservir un
maximum de sportifs de gymnase d'école
aussi je doute toutes les villes de
France c'est encore un secteur avec
scolarité et gymnase ou piscine je
rappelle que le dernier plan piscine
quand même remonte 1968 sous
Marie-Georges Buffet à l'époque et on
n'a pas beaucoup construit des choses
depuis donc même si l'accessibilité
beaucoup évolué il faut que la prise en
compte de cette différence évolue aussi
et l'inclusion par la même occasion donc
il y a encore du travail et la formation
permet de garantir ces choses là de se
prémunir de tout problème et d'assurer
aussi
une pratique dans une bonne forme de
sécurité s'agit pas de vouloir tout
faire et de le faire n'importe comment
et de le faire de façon constructive
pour que ce soit durable et surtout que
ce soit efficace parce que si on est mal
formé mais ça marche pas bien
c'est important oui et puis je
il y a des sportifs qui ont handicap
physique il y a beaucoup de sportifs qui
ont handicap psychiques également
ou mental et qui ont véritablement aussi
besoin de faire du sport et besoin comme
enfin comme tous si vous voulez c'est
une hygiène une hygiène de vie une
prévention
et ce qui est nécessaire quand même en
dehors du matériel en dehors des
infrastructures potentielles c'est aussi
bien sûr la formation La formation des
clubs la formation pour l'accueil
il faut connaître les différents types
de handicaps il faut rendre les choses
possibles donc c'est un vrai c'est une
sensibilisation et une formation pour
que et bien en définitive l'accueil soit
le plus adapté possible le plus
approprié possible et tout cela est tout
cela nécessite que
dont on soit très volontariste dans ce
domaine là mais moi je suis je suis une
grande confiance dans le sport français
en général parce que c'est quand même la
grande école de la solidarité et puis il
y a de la pétance pour pour beaucoup de
clubs de développer
des structures particulières de paraport
et
pour voir si les freins sont sont
financiers si les phrases sont de
matériel j'en suis pas sûr je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit un investissement
beaucoup plus important donc oui le
sport et le paraport une formidable
vitrine dans les dans les JO
jop dans les jeux de paris 2024 et
d'ailleurs nous serons ensemble enfin
nous serons je sais pas si vous y serez
d'ailleurs je serai le 8 octobre à Paris
à Bastille place de la Bastille pour une
grande journée autour du
parrasport pour lancer un petit peu
cette dynamique jusqu'en jusqu'en 2024
et vous y serez oui oui on se verra là
c'est la première journée paralympique
française elle est importante on a une
jeux olympique qui a été créée depuis
quelques années maintenant qui
correspond à la fête du sport et on
voulait avoir une équivalence au niveau
paralympique justement pour pouvoir
aussi rendre ce sport là où cette
pratique là attractive et puis la
montrer aux autres publics alors au lieu
de prendre la Bastille sous le plan
militaire on va prendre la Bastille sur
le plan sportif c'est pas plus mal
c'est moins belliqueux exactement
bien et vous pouvez poser des questions
je vais je vais c'est pas possible déjà
on sait pas je vois j'en lis une là il
faut rendre le sport accessible à tous
quels sont les leviers on en a parlé un
petit peu
mais allez-y il vient de lui financiers
il y a des leviers sociaux puis
simplement aussi la prise en compte de
la différence qui est pas encore bien
perçu dans notre pays
s'investir et être volontariste comme
vous dites c'est important mais parce
que on est compétents la matière et
qu'on sait comment prendre en charge ces
personnes là quel que soit le handicap
on a beaucoup par handicap physique les
par un sport oui bien sûr mais il y a
aussi des handicap invisibles et puis le
handicap intellectuel en effet la France
accueille en 2023 à Vichy les global
Games qui sont l'équivalent des Jeux
paralympiques pour une certaine
catégorie de personnes en déficience
intellectuelles de type trisomique etc
et c'est une opération importante pour
notre pays
qui contribue réellement du peuple en
général et puis surtout
donc il y a des freins psychologiques
malheureusement encore on en a
quelques-uns qu'on peut lever dès lors
qu'on est bien formé encore une fois le
vecteur formation est essentiel et puis
la compagne aussi plus que génération il
la comprenne différentes personnes coach
famille etc qui vivent mieux le handicap
et qui avance de façon beaucoup plus
sereine dans notre société grâce à ça
c'est important deuxième question pour
vous je crois
il y a un levier alors rendre le sport
accessible à tous je vais je vais
terminer quels sont les leviers bon il y
a un levier qui peut paraître Nodin mais
qui est quand même important pour
beaucoup de familles
ça peut être le vieil économique le
passeport qui a été mis en oeuvre par le
gouverneur enfin par la ministre des
Sports
il est accessible aux familles
bénéficiaires de la location de rentrée
scolaire mais il bénéficie aussi aux
familles d'enfants et jeunes en
situation de handicap donc pour ces
jeunes là ça peut leur permettre aussi
d'avoir un soutien financier pour parce
que bon une licence de sport qu'on fasse
du sport
quel que soit le sport il faut une
licence de sport il faut une assurance
bon et donc voilà ça c'est un c'est déjà
un sujet important ce soutien est
important et les leviers ensuite c'est
les leviers de la con de les leviers
disons de conviction que l'on peut
apporter au club de développer le
passeport et puis moi je crois que un
excellent
accélérateur quand nous avons des
témoins comme David qui voilà ont vécu
le sport vive le sport font du sport
du parasport son champion je crois que
ça a donné vraiment une image très très
positive pour tous les jeunes de notre
pays et je crois que c'est absolument
essentiel
quid des bénévoles dans les clubs de
paraspore quel état des lieux comment
développer le bénévolat on a tant donné
quand on a autant à donner qu'à recevoir
non
alors je vous laisse parler du du des
bénévoles dans les clubs de Paris sport
je crois que vous les connaissez mieux
que moi c'est un cours que je donne
lundi d'ailleurs on parle de cette
équilibre là entre salarié et bénévole
qui est pas de surfacile et qu'ils ont
de pouvoir dans les clubs mais j'ai
envie de dire simplement si on arrivait
enfin grâce à ces jeux paralympiques et
olympiques bien sûr c'est job de Paris
24 à réformer un peu le sport on aurait
aussi une approche du handicap qui soit
qui soit différente pardon et alors quid
des bénévoles dans les clubs de
parasport c'est quoi bénévoles tout
court la France vous le savez fonctionne
aussi avec beaucoup de bénévolats il
faut que ce statut change faut que le
sport évolue il faut que cette loi 1901
évolue aussi les clubs ne peuvent plus
vivre sur cette loi de 100 en permanence
avec des gens qui sont investis qui
n'ont rien en retour la varisation est
importante je pense peut-être dans
l'expérience dans le temps qu'on passe
en termes de trimestre en termes de de
retraite en termes de formation d'accès
à la formation par exemple pour les
personnes qui sont bénévoles ça peut
être une solution
donc oui ça investir et il y aura 45000
bénévoles pour Paris 2024 il faut que ça
ouvre d'autres portes ensuite pour que
les clubs puissent ensuite avancer dans
le temps c'est très important
tant à donner et à recevoir oui dans
tous les sens du terme parce que
on va accueillir pour la première fois
que je pars olympiques ce sera une
découverte pour beaucoup d'entre nous
alors nous en tant que sportif non mais
pour beaucoup d'entre nous et c'est vrai
que on est extrêmement curieux et
soucieux de savoir comment cet effet va
être transformé ensuite
Paris ne veut pas être qu'un one shot
uniquement une vitrine sportive et
vraiment engagée un processus très très
fort pour l'avenir il comprend
maintenant de sport parce qu'encore une
fois le sport c'est aussi l'inclusion
donc
toute personne bénévole qui se s’engager
et le quota est ouvert de bénévolat et
les inscriptions sont ouvertes pour
Paris 2024 olympique et paralympique en
ce sont des cas comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure à table ou non on a une chance
de pouvoir s'engager et de pouvoir donc
forcément contribuez nous aussi au
rayonnement de ce sport et rayonnement
de notre pays grâce à cet événement donc
c'est un problème qui est similaire aux
attaques Olympiques qui au club tout
simplement les lois 1920 qu'on connaît
tous
il faut qu'on réforme ces choses là et
qu'on fasse avancer les choses pour que
ce statut évolue et qu'il y a une réelle
contrepartie elle peut être d'ordre
financier parfois c'est ce qu'on
souhaite mais la possibilité être
d'ordre formation comme tout à l'heure
voilà un soutien important pour dire que
les gens qui s'engagent sont valorisés
derrière remercient bien sûr mais
valoriser et soutenu dans leur projet et
puis pourquoi pas matière de retraite on
a réussi à faire passer avec notre
commission d'athlètes du Sano SF le fait
que certains sportifs organisent depuis
très longtemps qui donne du temps pour
le pays etc puissent aussi cumuler à
certains de trimestres comme des
retraites parce que nous sommes
professionnels sur notre travail aussi
bien pourquoi pas dans les deux sens
c'est les bénévolats aussi voilà
bon c'est bien ça c'est des des perches
lancées pour les ministres qui qui
s'occupent des associations et des
bénévoles mais c'est un sujet très très
important effectivement pour faire en
sorte que le le bénévolat ne s'étiole
pas et vous avez parlé vous avez parlé
des bénévoles pour les Jeux Olympiques
et Paralympiques effectivement
45000 bénévoles vont être
recrutés formés pour ces jeux pour bien
guider les personnes enfin avec
différentes différentes fonctions et
parmi ces 45 000 bénévoles il y a 3000
bénévoles en situation de handicap qui
seront recrutés également pas que pour
les Jeux paralympiques ils feront tous
les jeux et Jeux paralympiques donc je
pense que c'est une très très belle
opération aussi d'inclusion
que nous allons porter que nous allons
porter à Paris 2024 avec voilà une belle
image de du bénévolat du bénévolat en
France on aime bien utiliser le terme
handicapable dans notre milieu dans
notre sphère handicapable oui dans le
sens où les gens sont parfois capables
aussi faire pas mal de choses ils ont
des compétences à apporter ils ont de
l'envie beaucoup d'envie et comme toute
personne il est pas question qu'on
exclut les personnes se sont les caps
pour ce bel événement sportif que sont
les Jeux olympiques ou paralympiques et
qui puissent intervenir comme vous dites
très justement d'un côté comme de
l'autre et alors je pour terminer afin
de terminer pour parler longtemps j'ai
rencontré à sa demande l'ambassadeur du
Japon
en France et il est venu me faire
voilà un compte rendu un petit peu
de retour d'expérience de ce qui s'était
passé au Japon pour ces Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques et notamment sur le les
dans les Jeux paralympiques alors vous
savez qu'ils ont organisé des jeux dans
des circonstances particulièrement
difficile en pleine covid son spectateur
enfin bref c'était c'était une vraie
difficulté mais ça a été une vraie
réussite et il me disait que le les Jeux
paralympiques avaient
profondément changé son pays
et
l'image et la perception du handicap
dans dans le pays et je crois qu'il faut
vraiment capitaliser sur tout cela et
qu'ils continuent de travailler à une
inclusion de plus en plus
[Musique]
importantes et volontaires en
capitalisant sur ce qui s'était passé
ces Jeux Olympiques donc vraiment
j'espère que nous pourrons enfin
j'espère nous allons l'accompagner bien
entendu il faut que nous l'accompagnions
parce qu'en fait tout cela est une
question une vraie question sociétale
l'inclusion il faut que nous incluions
tout simplement parce que on avait
peut-être trop mis à l'écart
c'est ça en fait
et des pays sont bien plus avancés que
le nôtre mais nous y travaillons
d'arrache-pied nous avons fait beaucoup
beaucoup nous avons beaucoup avancé dans
l'inclusion scolaire dans le travail
dans le sport dans la culture
et voilà cette les Jeux
paralympiques vont nous donner je
l'espère vont donner à réfléchir à notre
société nous donner un boost pour que
cette inclusion puisse se voilà ce
réaliser concrètement à tous les niveaux
et ainsi que accompagnés de
l'accessibilité universelle qui est
indispensable pour que l'inclusion se
fasse dans des bonnes conditions
dans les deux côtés la sphère olympique
et paralympique les jeux de transformer
vraiment une société moi je suis de
Grenoble et j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
me raconte l'histoire des Jeux
Olympiques de Grenoble 68 tout ce que
l'héritage a permis de laisser de créer
on parle de l'hôpital voilà on parle de
la ville de Grenoble de l'Université des
autoroutes etc une ville qui est passée
de 80000 à 160 000 habitants 150 000
habitants c'est un petit village au
départ et pour devenir une grande
capitale des Alpes donc il y a tout un
process qui est très important et qui
crée vraiment un changement en
profondeur d'une société parce qu'il est
olympique et paralympique c'est vraiment
les deux qui changent
et sur le plan culturel le Japon a
forcément appris beaucoup comme l'on
fait aussi nos amis anglophones en
Angleterre et Londres on suit vraiment
transformé la société grâce à ce projet
olympique paralympique qui encore une
fois j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus je
m'en excuse mais ne pas qu'une vitrine
sportive de haut niveau c'est un impact
très fort et profond pour une société
qui grâce à cet engagement d'abord de
travaux etc d'accueil permet vraiment de
changer le son en profondeur donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose de précieux et
pour ceux qui sont encore dans le doute
je vous engage à venir faire un tour à
Paris et vous verrez en 2024 comment la
ville et comment on espère le peuple va
marionner grâce à un Gazost projet à ses
projets
bien j'ai une nouvelle question
peut-être la dernière mais
oui ce soir la dernière j'ai le chef le
chef qui me dit que ce sera la dernière
mettre du temps le maître du temps oui
mais il faut un chef dans la salle
y a-t-il les déplacements des athlètes
prévus dans les territoires comment
macédoineurs de l'événement et du Sport
Santé en lien avec les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques alors sur la première
partie de questions oui on a des
ambassadeurs autant olympiques que
paralympique qui sont tout à fait en
maison de se déplacer qui sont nommés
pour Paris 204 pour cette raison là qui
font un travail fantastique
j'étais encore hier au téléphone avec
Émilie Gomis qui travaille sur ces
choses-là perle bouge en aviron aussi et
pour la partie sport santé nous sommes
bientôt à la veille d'une nouvelle
semaine sentez-vous sport mise en place
par le scénosf pour valoriser cette
partie là donc c'est quelque chose qui
est très pertinent et nous en tant que
sportive au niveau on est amené à
témoigner
à partager et à venir aussi récompenser
ces entreprises qui s'investissent dans
le cadre de la santé par le sport avec
des Trophées des lauréats donc bien sûr
je vous engage à aller sur le site du
Séno SF comité nationale olympique
sportif français la semaine santé vous
sport voilà s e n T e Z et non sa n mais
il y a un jeu de mot sympathique bien
sûr que les athlètes sont des
ambassadeurs et on en a quelques-uns
pour parler de 4 bien sûr
très bien et bien c'était la dernière
question donc je vais nous allons
arrêter là et
merci pour ce temps
je voudrais très sincèrement
remercier David smetadine d'avoir
d'avoir passé ces trois quarts d'heure
avec vous tous et avec moi et tout ce
que je peux lui souhaiter c'est de
continuer engranger les médailles aux JO
P au jeu de Paris dans deux ans et en
tout cas moi personnellement il force
mon admiration et je suis voilà et je le
remercie d'être cet ambassadeur
formidable et de nous avoir d'avoir
échangé sur sa passion avec vous tous
cet après-midi merci à tous merci
[Applaudissements]